So your goal for this quiz, is to finish
modifying the crawl_web procedure, so that instead of returning just
the index, it returns both an index and a graph.
And the graph gives the link structure. The graph should
be a dictionary, where the entries in the graph are
a URL, which is the target page, and a list.
Which is the pages that link to that target. So
to test your graph making code, we've provided a sample
site at this URL. So if that's the link
that you pass in as the seed for the crawl_web.
It's going to crawl in the site we set up.
And there's an index page that looks like this, it's
got five links on it. And, those links go to different web pages. So the first
one goes to my favorite hummus recipe. So, there's a link from
index.html. And it goes to the page hummus.html. And if we
follow that link, we get to a page that
has no links on it. This second link. Goes
to page arsenic.html. And that page includes a link
the Nickel Chef page. And the Nickel Chef page
includes a link to kathleen.html. And that page has
no links on it. And the third link on
the index page, also goes to the kathleen.html page.
And there's two more links on the start page.
The first one goes to the Nickel Chef page,
which we've already seen. And the last link, goes
to the Zinc Chef. And from the Zinc Chef
page, we have two more links, we have one to
the Nickel page. And we have one to the Arsenic
Chef's famous hummus recipe page. So this is a pretty
complicated link structure, although it's very simple compared to the
things that we actually find on the web. But your goal
is to be able to produce this graph, by modifying
the code that we have for crawl_web. And then once
we have the page ranks, we'll be able to use
PageRank to find the best page. To find a hummus recipe.
So for this site, the graph that your
crawl_web should produce, should have entries that show these
connections, so there should be an entry where the
URL is the urank/index.html, I'm leaving out the beginning
of the URL. And the entries should be a list of all the pages that, that links
to there. So they're going to be five pages. All
five of these should be in the list here.
There should be the Hummus page, there should
be the Arsenic page, and the other three pages.
The order that. Links appear in this list doesn't
matter, it's correct as long as you have all
five of the links that you can reach from
the index.html page. The kathleen.html page, doesn't have any
outgoing links, so the entry for kathleen.html should be
an empty list. So see if you can figure
out how to change the code for crawl_web, to produce as its second
output, a graph that shows the structure of the web pages that we crawled.